before I died I thought there was
nothing after death
but the best was yet to come
welcome back to life mark can you see
yourself can you feel your whole buddy
Lazarus
ladies and gentlemen of the future my
name is Mark Jarvis and I'm the first
man average be resurrected
this is giant step in the history of
medicine the wonder what will happen
from now on if I'll ever be normal we
call it mind rider if you connect it to
your head you can record your thoughts
if I managed to record my memories well
they still belong to me
when you get rid of everything you have
to work what's left
[Music]
I was going to die
I was going to disappear forever
and I'm alive again
I'm alive these memories aren't being
erased but you think reanimating you
would be some miracle I'm afraid there's
nothing we can do
I don't believe you
I don't believe you ever really cared
about my baby
you chose to stop living so he could
have another life
it's the world I always dreamed of I'm
sorry I shouldn't have brought it up no
it's okay I wanted to talk to you too
about it okay then I have a question
sure so everywhere I look they say the
body needs to be cryin eyes Daz soon as
possible after you're declared legally
dead
so yourselves don't deteriorate but no
matter what they did it would take
several hours even a day or more to
complete the process the damage will be
huge not to mention the harm caused by
the disease and the treatment before he
died yeah I'm undoing any more chemo I
already saw my father spend years of his
life fighting his disease dying little
by little I won't go through that and as
far as the time between death and cryin
ization well I have a plan to make sure
that they get to me quickly and start
pumping blood right away but how will
you do that I mean you would have to
know the exact circumstances of your
death yeah I'm gonna make sure that we
can close by and then I'm in good
physical shape when the time comes
I gotta die before the disease gets
ahold of me and I need your help
you